The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
[APPLAUSE]
BASSAM SHAKHASHIRI:
Thank you very much.
Good afternoon, everyone.
It's almost evening.
It's a pleasure
to be back at MIT.
It's always a pleasure to
be back in the Boston area
because this is
where we first lived,
when my family and I came to
the United States in 1957.
In fact, we arrived
here September 17, 1957.
My dad came as a visiting
professor to Harvard
from the American
University of Beirut.
And then Harvard said,
stay another year stay,
another year.
He never went back.
So I enrolled at
Boston University.
My dad then moved to NIH.
Both my parents
are deceased now.
But the Boston area
is very special to us
because it was the
first place that we
lived in this great and
wonderful country of ours.
And then, I'm very,
very happy to be back
as a guest of Professor Lippert,
and the students in his class,
and the colleagues.
And I promise you a good
time, if you pay attention.
[LAUGHTER]
So what I really
would like you to do
is sit back and
relax because I'm
going to share with
you, to begin with,
some important convictions
about what it is that we do
in science and why we do it.
I wish I had more
time to go in depth.
But I just want to go
quickly through some
of these convictions
that I hold very deeply.
So let's see if this
is going to work here.
I want to see your faces.
OK.
I can still see your faces.
So Science is Fun and
the Joy of Learning.
That's the title
of my presentation,
Science is Fun and
the Joy of Learning.
And every word is
carefully selected.
You know, English is
my second language.
So I think about every
word and its meaning.
I also want to say that
it's a pleasure for me
to see some old friends here,
but also to make new friends.
And to see someone who
watched me in Singapore, when
I was in Singapore--
Where are you?
Right there, yeah, yeah--
about three years ago.
So welcome.
So what I'd like to
say to you immediately,
that your brain
and my brain will
be different after
this presentation,
if you pay attention.
If you don't pay attention,
I can't do much about it.
But both my brain and your
brain will be different.
35, 40 years ago, when students
went to medical school,
they were told that
the brain is an organ.
It doesn't change very much.
But now we know more.
Through the neurosciences,
we know a lot more.
We know about plasticity.
In fact, changes in
the brain happen.
That's what education
is all about.
That's what learning is about,
if those changes were not
happening.
So I just want to share with
you the importance of being
focused and paying attention.
We live in the most advanced
society in humankind.
And these advances are
due to advances in science
and in technology.
I want you to think of
this statement I just made.
Everything we enjoy
now is the result
of advances in science
and in technology.
The advances are so
great, much greater
than we knew 50 years
ago when I first
came to this country,
or a hundred years ago,
or 200 years ago, or 500 years
ago, a thousand years ago.
A long time ago,
technology drove society.
The printing press was invented.
Electricity lit the world before
we learned about the electron,
before the electron
was discovered.
There are all kinds
of connections
between science and technology.
But nowadays, it's science
that drives technology.
Our ancestors were very good.
They built cities.
They built canals.
They built pyramids.
But now, we can build
pyramids at the atomic level.
You've seen pictures of them.
A great deal of
wonderful transformations
have happened because
of advances in science
and in technology.
And it is the brain,
our brain, that is
responsible for those changes.
We're all capable of doing
good things, each one of us.
And each one of us is
capable of doing evil.
And that's why we have
to be selective about how
we use the results of
those advances in science
and in technology.
These are different parts
of the control mechanisms
that we know about
now for the brain.
So please pay attention
and bear with me.
You came to see some experiments
and some demonstrations.
I promise I will get to them.
[LAUGHTER]
But I want you to understand
the perspective and the context
for doing those experiments
and those demonstrations.
So we all like to
say that chemistry
is the central science.
And it is the central science.
I like to say it's
the familiar science.
In fact, what I'd
like to say, it's
the science of the familiar
because everything around us
is made of chemicals.
The air that we
breathe is a mixture
of usually good chemicals.
The food that we eat is
a mixture of chemicals.
The clothes that we wear
are made of chemicals.
Our own bodies are
made of chemicals.
What goes on inside
our bodies is
nothing but a series of
biochemical reactions.
The medicine that we
take when we are sick
is a mixture of chemicals.
The drugs that some
people very stupidly
experiment with are chemicals.
Ah, some of you are smiling.
I'm connecting with the already.
That's why we need to
learn about chemicals,
their proper handling, safe
handling, proper disposal,
their benefits.
It's so complex,
but it's beautiful.
Beauty is part of science.
It's an essential
part of science.
Now having told you that
everything around us
is made of chemicals, I'd
like to ask each one of you
right now to reach out.
It's OK, Lou.
It's part of the effect.
It already had the
same effect on you.
So that's good.
I'd like to ask each
one of you right now
to reach out and
touch a chemical.
Go ahead and do it right now.
Somebody's tapping on
somebody's shoulder.
Somebody's is pulling
somebody's hair.
Don't pull it too long.
Somebody is reaching
out in the air.
Yes.
Chemicals are all around us.
And we want to learn and enjoy
the beautiful chemical world
that we live in.
That's why I say chemistry is
the science of the familiar.
It's the science
of the familiar.
So I want to share with you
for just a few short seconds
the theme that I have selected
for the American Chemical
Society.
As Professor Lippert said,
I will be the president
beginning January 1.
But I'm not waiting
till then because I
want to get a good head
start and get going.
The theme I selected
is advancing chemistry,
communicating chemistry;
advancing chemistry,
communicating chemistry.
And I want to call your
attention to the ACS mission
statement.
One of the worst things
that a presenter can do
is show a slide and
then proceed to read it.
It's an insult to the audience.
You can read it.
But forgive me.
I don't mean to insult you.
I want to share with you
the emphasis about this.
So it says, "To advance the
broader chemistry enterprise
and its practitioners
for the benefit of Earth
and its people."
Such a profound statement, I
only wish I had written it.
And then there's the ACS vision,
"Improving people's lives
through the transforming
power of chemistry."
"Transform" is a
very powerful word.
That's what happens to us
when we become educated.
This is what happens to us when
we become learned individuals.
This is what happens
to societies when they
become advanced and learned.
They are transformed.
I've selected four initiatives.
Next year is the
sesquicentennial
of the Land Grant Act.
And the Land Grant
Act, as some of you
know, and I'm about to tell
you if you didn't know it,
transformed America.
MIT is a land grant institution.
Did you know that?
Raise your hand if you knew
that MIT was a land grant
institution.
OK.
Raise your hand now if you
know that MIT is a land grant
institution?
Everybody-- right?
I mean, look, I asked
you to pay attention.
[LAUGHTER]
I said your brains
will be different.
My brain is being
different already
because I can tell
from your reactions,
when it is visual reactions,
and also from your sound
that you're sharing with me.
So we're going to mark the
sesquicentennial of the Land
Grant Act at the national
ACS meeting in San Diego
and Philadelphia by
looking retrospectively
at what chemistry departments
have done in the past 150
years.
So we educate ourselves
about our heritage.
What I'm really most
interested in is
what we're going to do in
the future, what you're
going to do in the future?
I'm not going to be
around much longer.
I hope a long time.
But not as long as
you're going to be.
So we want to be prospective.
We want a glance in
the real view mirror.
But we want to look
ahead so we can
be participants and leaders
in transformations that
are good for our human society.
Our second initiative deals
with appointing a blue ribbon
commission to examine the
purposes of graduate education
and research in the
chemical sciences.
Look at the purposes.
Why do we have graduate programs
in the chemical sciences?
Has the German model
served us well?
Is it appropriate
for the 21st century?
We make promises to
graduate students
when they come to
graduate school.
Do we keep those promises?
Look at the duration of the
postdoctoral appointment now.
It's getting longer and longer.
So we talk about
employment issues.
We also look at the profile
of the graduate students,
diversity, as well
as international part
of the profile.
And we want to, of
course, remember
that the graduate students
were undergraduates before.
And before that, they
were in precollege.
So we're going to segue to that.
But the focus is on
this level right now.
There'll be listening sessions.
There'll be opportunities to
interact via email, webinars,
with this blue ribbon commission
that I have appointed.
The third initiative is to
help the public understand
the science of climate change.
The science of climate
change, not the politics,
not the economics, but the
science of climate change.
What is a greenhouse gas?
What makes it a greenhouse gas?
Did you know that any molecule
with three atoms or more
in the gaseous phase
is a greenhouse gas?
Did you know that?
Yes or no?
You didn't know it, right.
Well, I just told you.
OK.
Every molecule in
the gaseous phase,
that has three atoms or
more, is a greenhouse gas.
But they're not all effective.
And why aren't
they all effective?
And what does it
take for a molecule
to become a greenhouse gas?
We all know about
dipole moments.
Yes.
You know about dipole moments?
OK.
So what I'd like you to do is
make connections between what
you know and what
you're hearing me
say now because
that's how we learn.
And that's how we share the
knowledge with each other.
So it takes a dipole
moment to effect, right?
You're shaking your head.
And I'm beginning to
connect with you, right?
But there are molecules with two
atoms in the gaseous phase that
have a dipole moment too.
Carbon monoxide, right?
Well, it's not a greenhouse gas.
How come?
So what does it take
to be a greenhouse gas?
Think about it.
Here's the big question.
How does the vibrational
energy change into heat energy?
I'm not going to ask any
one individual to tell me
the answer to that one.
But I'm asking you
to think about it.
How does the vibrational
energy change into heat energy?
You know, most of the air
is nitrogen and oxygen.
But now, we're putting
greenhouse gases in there,
more than we did before.
Why?
Because the
Industrial Revolution
has been so successful,
extremely successful.
This is why we have the most
advanced society in humankind.
But because of the
Industrial Revolution,
we put more carbon
dioxide in the air.
We put more CO2 gas in the air.
Is that a good thing?
Up to a point,
it's a good thing.
If it weren't for
the greenhouse gases,
the surface of the
planet would be as cold
as it is on Mars and life as
we know it would not exist.
So there are good
and not so good
things about the
greenhouse gases.
And that's what this third
initiative deals about.
The fourth one is to
consider the possibility
of establishing an ACS high
school teacher fellowship
program.
We will be hearing
about this later
on from reading
chemical engineering
news and other sources.
So that's briefly what
I want to focus on.
It's not the only thing.
But that's what I want to
focus on for next year.
So advancing
chemistry, how do how
do we do it, through research.
Research is so enjoyable.
It's so rewarding.
We ask questions.
We want to know the answers.
We're curious.
Why is the sky blue?
Scattering, you're to
tell me scattering.
OK, that's good.
OK.
[LAUGHTER]
Why do leaves change
color in the fall?
One of the most beautiful
experiences I had in my life,
when we first came
to Boston in 1957,
a colleague of my dad at Harvard
took us to New Hampshire,
to Vermont, in the fall.
It just-- it was--
I can't use adequate
words to describe
the beauty of the
chemical transformations
that were happening
in the leaves
and how the chlorophyll
reaction shuts down.
And all these other
colors are there already.
But we don't see them because
they're masked by chlorophyll.
And just understanding
that and asking questions
is what we're trying to do, both
in research and in education.
Of course advanced chemistry
by being innovative as well.
So I'd like to just take a
couple of moments to tell you
that in society
today, we have two
sectors, the science-rich sector
and the science-poor sector.
Who is in the
science-rich sector?
Colleges and universities,
parts of industry,
the national laboratories.
Who is in the
science-poor sector?
Everyone else.
And those of us who
are fortunate to be
in the science-rich
sector have an obligation
to the people who are in
the science-poor sector.
I want you for a moment to
think about science-rich
and science-poor.
But I also want you to think
about what you hear on the news
now daily and cross
out the word "science"
and cross out the word
"science from the second one.
And look at the
turmoil that we have.
There's a gap that is
widening at an alarming
rate between those of us
who are rich in knowledge
and otherwise, and
those who are not.
And it's incumbent upon
us to narrow that gap.
We have to do it for a lot
of profound societal reasons.
But I'll give you
one crass reason
why it's important for those of
us in the science-rich sector
to communicate with the
science-poor sector.
And you know what
that crass reason is.
The people here, in
this sector here, they
pay for what it is that we do
in the science-rich sector,
government funds,
private foundation funds.
So we need to be thinking about
our role as science students,
as scientists, as learned
individuals in this regard.
All right.
So there's scientific
competence,
which is what we acquire
by doing research
through education.
There's scientific expertise.
But there's also
science literacy.
Our goal should be to increase
the level of science literacy
among people in the
science-poor sector.
Science literacy is the
appreciation of science
without a deep knowledge of
chemistry, physics, or biology,
or any other science.
It's an appreciation.
Let me give you an analogy to
make this point as clearly as I
know how.
And this analogy
comes from sports.
I know as a classroom teacher
the danger of using analogies
because you remember
the analogy,
and not the real thing
that I'm talking about.
Just as we have professional
football players, baseball
players, hockey players, and
so on, we have sports fans.
Without those sports
fans, you know
the interprofessional sports
enterprise would be nothing.
You also know that's
not an exaggeration.
So what we need,
we need scientists
and we need science fans.
And we want those
science fans not
to be sitting in the stands
as passive spectators.
We want them to follow
what we're doing.
Some of them might even
show up on the playing field
to become scientists like us.
But we have to pay
attention to them
so we can improve the
level of science literacy.
Communications.
There are many elements
to communications.
I just list five of them here.
One is to inform, to engage--
that's what I hope
to do very shortly.
I promised you I'll
do experiments.
They're engaging.
I'm going to get to that--
to educate, to advocate,
and to persuade.
There are other parts of it.
There's entertain, all kinds
of things you can think about.
But those are the
five I want to try
to focus on as important
elements of communication.
In the scientific community
we communicate with each other
very well.
But we don't do it as
well yet with people
in the science-poor sector.
So we have to work on that.
One purpose of
communicating chemistry
is to showcase
chemistry at its best
in addressing significant
human and societal issues.
It's very important that we
do that, very, very important
that we do that.
Here's a statement from
a very famous person.
Everyone knows this
person by name.
And he said, "Most of the
fundamental ideas of science
are essentially m
and may, as a rule,
be expressed in a language
comprehensible to everyone."
You think about that.
He said most of the
fundamental ideas of science
are essentially simple,
or maybe simple to him.
But no, that's just a joke.
Now, you think about
what he's saying.
OK.
So we have to find ways to
improve our communication
skills to the public at large.
And so I want to mention
to you very briefly
an activity we do
at the Wisconsin
Initiative for Science Literacy,
asking graduate students
to include in their thesis
a chapter, explaining
the research that they just
finished, to their mother,
to their grandfather,
to their neighbor,
to anyone, to their former
high school classmates.
So that they get to appreciate
what it is that someone spent
five, six years,
working hard, using
taxpayers' money and
other people's money,
to improve knowledge and to
give us rewarding experiences.
And the goal, as I say, is
to explain the candidate's
scholarly research
and its significance
to a wider audience,
that includes
family members, friends, civic
groups, newspaper reporters,
state legislator, and so on.
And if you do this,
we give you $500.
We're beyond $10 now.
We're beyond $10
among the graduates.
This is catching on.
And we will assist in the
public dissemination of this.
So I'm going to tell you how
you can find out more about this
because you can
read those chapters.
We have them posted
them on my website.
My website is www--
they all start with www,
you know that, right?
And then scifun--
S-C-I-F-U-N-- .org.
Somebody is writing it down.
You don't have to write it down.
Just say it quietly a couple
of times, scifun.org--
S-C-I-F-U-N-- .org,
scifun.org, scifun.org.
Now, this is how
we memorize things.
But why do we memorize things?
To store them in
our memory banks?
They use them.
To use them.
So I'm going to check
with my web master
in the next couple of days
to see how many new hits
we get from the Cambridge area.
See if anybody's
been to my website.
OK.
All right.
The great master
Leonardo said, "There
is no higher or lower
knowledge, but one only,
flowing out of experimentation.
We're getting close to
my keeping my promise,
keeping my promise.
That's what you came here for.
So I'm going to do
some experiments.
And my latest book is
volume 5 in this series.
It deals with color, light,
vision, and perception.
It deals with what happens
in front of the eye.
But now because of
advances in neurosciences,
we learn more about what
happens behind the eye.
So that's included
in this book here.
And there's a little flyer
that you may pick up as you
walked in or when you walk out.
And if you have a favorite
high school teacher,
you might want to give
him a copy as a Christmas
gift or a holiday
gift, if you wish to.
The book has been out
now since February.
This is the cover of the book.
What are these three
things that you see here?
What do they look like?
AUDIENCE: Drops of water.
BASSAM SHAKHASHIRI:
Mumble, mumble, mumble.
I like that because
everybody saying things--
huh?
Are they paperweights?
They could be.
They're actually water droplets.
That's what are.
They're water droplets,
as some of you said.
So here's an experiment
that I want--
the first experiment I
want to ask to look at.
This is a checkerboard.
This is about perception
because you're
going to be seeing things now.
And the brain, the brain
sometimes plays tricks on us.
So here's the checkerboard.
And you see this
object right here.
And you see it casts a shadow.
So my question to
you is, is the shade
in square of number 1 the same
as the shade in square number
2, yes or no?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
AUDIENCE: No.
BASSAM SHAKHASHIRI:
How many say yes?
Raise your hand if you say yes.
And how many say no?
More people say no.
So we have to train
ourself to do this.
Now, remember now, this
one is labeled number 1.
This is labeled number 2.
I'm going to now cover this.
And now, you see that they
both have the same shade.
You see that, right?
So those of you who said yes
before probably have seen this.
[LAUGHTER]
And you know what?
Your brain is
using the knowledge
that you had from before.
That's great.
So let's look at
this one more time.
So I take it off.
You see.
So what's going on here?
The shadow is telling
the brain something.
And we have to develop
the skills with our brains
to sort out the information, and
be very careful about it, so we
have the proper interpretation.
So this is when I cover it now.
You see this shadow
cannot be seen.
And that's how we
started with it.
So we have to make connections.
We have to make
good connections.
We don't want to have
any impedance problems.
That's what we
don't want to have.
And I want to show
you why we want
to do experiments
and demonstrations,
why we want to be engaging.
This is why.
That's why.
You just look at those faces.
And each one of them is engaged.
Engagement is important.
But what's really important
is what happens after that.
So we're going to
now get into what
happens as you become engaged.
Lights out, please.
Because we're going to do
some experiments, in addition
to the one we did.
Yes.
I know you've waited too long.
I know.
When we do experiments, we'll
obey all the safety rules.
You notice I have my goggles on.
Did you notice that?
I just pointed it
out as a reminder.
For those of you who noticed
and those of you who didn't, you
just saw that I have them on.
I have a fire
extinguisher right here.
It's ready to be used, just
in case something goes out
of control.
I'm not planning on anything
going out of control.
But we have it as a
safety precaution.
So what I'm going to do is
take a match and strike it.
You like that, right?
[LAUGHTER]
So this is an example of what
we call a combustion reaction.
I'm going to light a candle.
And--
AUDIENCE: Whoa.
BASSAM SHAKHASHIRI: --I'm
going to-- whoa is right, see.
Engagement.
I want to tell you
something that I
have observed over the years.
I've been doing these
demonstrations for over 40
years.
Youngsters and people
in retirement homes
are not inhibited
like the rest of us.
So we have to allow ourselves
to express ourselves.
So this is an example of
a combustion reaction.
And it is, of course,
related to Michael Faraday.
You know who Michael
Faraday was, right?
He used to gather young
people around Christmas time
at the Royal Institution and
do experiments with them.
And one of his most
famous lectures
is on the chemical
history of the candle.
So what I'm going to
do now, because you're
paying good attention,
I'm going to reach back
into my back pocket
and get my wallet out.
What do people usually
keep in their wallets?
AUDIENCE: Money.
BASSAM SHAKHASHIRI: Money.
What else?
AUDIENCE: Credit cards.
BASSAM SHAKHASHIRI:
Credit cards.
What else?
AUDIENCE: Driver's license.
BASSAM SHAKHASHIRI:
Driver's license,
if you're old
enough to have one.
What else?
AUDIENCE: Pictures.
BASSAM SHAKHASHIRI: Pictures,
all kinds of things.
So what I'm going to do now
is I'm going to reach in here.
I'm going to take a
dollar bill and I'm
going to put it into the
flame, just like that.
AUDIENCE: Wow.
BASSAM SHAKHASHIRI:
Was that too fast?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
BASSAM SHAKHASHIRI:
Well, I asked you to pay
close attention, didn't I?
I'm trying to engage your brain.
So that was not a
real dollar bill.
[LAUGHTER]
That was a fake dollar bill.
That was a phony dollar bill.
It's called flash paper.
What we always do in science
is repeat the experiment.
So I take out what looks
like a dollar bill.
But it's not a real dollar bill.
I bring it close to the flame.
It disappears into thin air.
It looks like magic.
I love magic.
Magic is engaging,
but not informative.
Magic is engaging.
So this is paper that has
been treated with chemicals so
that when it burns, it
doesn't leave any ash behind.
It's called flash paper.
And so what are the chemicals
that are used for this?
You want to think
about this, right.
So you want to educate yourself
about it if you want to.
And you might want
to go to my website
to learn more about this.
How do you get to my website?
AUDIENCE: www.funsci.org.
BASSAM SHAKHASHIRI: OK.
You got it.
So now I would
like to ask someone
in the audience to
volunteer to help me
with the next experiment.
Who wants to help?
Well, let me tell you first
what I need help with, OK.
[LAUGHTER]
I'd like someone in the audience
to let me borrow from them
a real $1 bill.
Is there someone
in the audience who
would let me--
who would trust me
with a real $1
bill or a $5 bill?
Steve, how about
a $20 bill, huh?
You got a $20 bill?
OK.
Here's a $1 bill.
It's a real $1 bill.
You know what I'm going
to do with it, don't you?
You know where this is going.
So combustion, combustion is--
AUDIENCE: You did say borrow.
BASSAM SHAKHASHIRI: Huh?
BASSAM SHAKHASHIRI:
I did say borrow.
You know what?
That's a very important
observation that you made
and you are reporting it.
Because the whole exchange
for the benefit of society
works on the element of trust.
You trusted me
with this $1 bill.
So I did say borrow, which
means I'm going to give it back.
AUDIENCE: Right.
BASSAM SHAKHASHIRI:
I didn't say what
form it's going to be
in when I give it back.
[LAUGHTER]
So, well, I have
a jar right here.
And I have in this jar--
what does it look like?
I have a liquid.
What does it look like?
It looks like?
AUDIENCE: Water.
BASSAM SHAKHASHIRI:
It looks like water.
The way we described this
liquid is to say it's
a clear and colorless liquid,
which is what water is.
So I'm going to take
this liquid and--
so I want everybody to
see the jar right here,
get this out of the way.
I'm going to take
the dollar bill.
I'm going to soak it in this
clear and colorless liquid,
which looks like water.
And I'm going to fish it
out using those tongs.
You see, it's dripping
like any wet object would.
And then I'm going to
take it to the flame.
Take a good look at it now.
It may be last time you see it.
So here is the dollar
bill on fire, or is it?
AUDIENCE: No.
BASSAM SHAKHASHIRI: But you
did see a flame, didn't you?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
BASSAM SHAKHASHIRI: So now I ask
you, can this liquid be water?
AUDIENCE: No.
BASSAM SHAKHASHIRI: You
know from experience
that water does not burn
under these conditions.
So I will tell you
what's in this jar.
This clear and
colorless liquid is
a mixture of rubbing alcohol
and water, isopropyl alcohol
and water.
You know also from experience
that when you burn alcohol,
what color flame do you see?
It's kind of bluish.
Do you remember what
color flame you saw here?
It was a little yellowish.
That's because we also added a
little bit of sodium chloride
in there.
The eye is more sensitive
to the yellow color
than it is to the blue color.
So we added the sodium chloride
to enhance the visibility
of what's going on.
How can sodium chloride
enhance the visibility?
So we're exciting the
electrons and the sodium ions.
They go to a higher
energy state.
Do you remember all the
stuff that you learned
in atomic structure, and so on?
Make connections.
Make connections with that.
So I give you back
this dollar bill
because I said I
would borrow it.
So here it is.
So what does it feel like?
Of course, it's wet.
It's 50% water, 50% alcohol.
So wait a little
bit until it dries.
And then you can--
so thank you very much.
Give her a hand for
helping out with this.
[APPLAUSE]
So when you burn something
that has carbon in it,
you get carbon dioxide.
Carbon dioxide is a gas
at room temperature.
We can't see it because
it has no color.
And we can't smell it
because it has no odor.
But everyone knows
about carbon dioxide gas
because you know about
carbonated beverages.
In fact, they're called
They have carbon
dioxide in them.
I'm going to do an
experiment right now
so that we can learn a bit more
about how much carbon dioxide
is dissolved in this liquid.
And to do this experiment, I'm
going to use a baby bottle.
[LAUGHTER]
You remember that, huh?
So this baby bottle has
been modified slightly.
I have replaced the nipple
that has the hole in it where
the milk flows out, with the
rubber bulb from a medicine
dropper.
And this is a very
strong piece of rubber.
I'm going to try to
show you how strong it
is by attempting to blow air in
it to see if I can inflate it.
Here we go.
Can't do it.
It's very, very strong.
So now, please listen carefully
to this very familiar sound
as I open the can.
You've all done this
or seen someone do it.
Here we go.
AUDIENCE: Yes.
BASSAM SHAKHASHIRI:
Did you hear that?
Now, the can is open
to the atmosphere.
That's the sound from the metal.
I'm going to take the liquid
and put it in this baby bottle.
What do you see?
You see fizz.
You see bubbles.
What kind of bubbles are those?
They're carbon dioxide bubbles.
Where are they coming from?
They're coming from the
drink, from the liquid.
But the pressure now is
open to the atmosphere.
And that's why
they're bubbling out.
So I'm going to fill it to
the top, take the screw cap
and tighten it.
What should I do next?
AUDIENCE: Shake it.
BASSAM SHAKHASHIRI: You've done
this experiment before, huh?
So I shake it.
And now you see how much
carbon dioxide is dissolved
in this carbonated beverage.
There's so much carbon
dioxide in there
it's able to partially inflate
this strong piece of rubber,
that neither I, nor
any other human being,
can inflate with all
the powers of our lungs.
But you already
know that there is
a lot of carbon dioxide
in drinks like this
because what do you do
after you take a sip or two?
AUDIENCE: Burp.
BASSAM SHAKHASHIRI: Burp.
Yes, you burp.
When you burp, please do
it gently and politely.
Your burp because the
carbon dioxide gas
is coming out of the liquid.
So now let's see
if I can release
the pressure a little bit here.
I do it carefully.
If I don't do it carefully,
what will happen?
I will make a mess.
You're right.
It'll spread out.
But I don't want to
make a mess because
this carbonated beverage
has, among other things
in it, sugar.
And that sugar is sticky.
I don't want to have.
So there it is.
It's open to the atmosphere now.
And the carbon dioxide
still bubbles out.
You know from experience that
when the drink goes flat,
it doesn't taste as good.
Right?
You're shaking your heads.
Why doesn't it
taste good, as good?
Because all the carbon
dioxide has disappeared.
So why do we like
carbonated beverages?
Some of them have
alcohol in them.
Some of them have some
sugar or sweetener in them.
We like them because when we
put the liquid in our mouth,
the tiny gas bubbles
come out of liquid
and they tingle us
under the tongue
and give us a
pleasant sensation.
So that's about
carbon dioxide gas.
It is a colorless and
it is a odorless gas.
Now, what I'm going to
do is an experiment using
another form of carbon dioxide.
It's called dry ice.
Dry ice is solid carbon dioxide.
And you'll notice
I'm putting what on?
AUDIENCE: Gloves.
BASSAM SHAKHASHIRI:
Putting gloves.
And I'm going to
open this bucket
and pick up three chunks
of carbon dioxide, solid.
This is solid carbon dioxide.
It's temperature is
minus 78 degrees Celsius.
It's very cold.
That's why I use these
gloves to protect
my hands from frostbite.
These gloves are not
very good insulators.
But for this purpose,
they're good because I'm not
squeezing on the dry ice.
Dry ice changes from being a
solid to a gas by a process we
call sublimation.
Sublimation is
happening right now.
But we can't see it.
How come we can't see it?
Because carbon dioxide
is gas, is what?
AUDIENCE: Invisible.
BASSAM SHAKHASHIRI:
It's invisible.
It has no color.
By the way, if you
ever see a colored gas,
you run away from it.
You heard me.
If you ever see a colored
gas, you run away from it
because all colored
gases are poisonous.
All colored gases are poisonous.
The converse is not true.
There are some colorless gases
that are deadly poisonous,
including the close
relative to carbon dioxide?
AUDIENCE: Carbon monoxide.
BASSAM SHAKHASHIRI:
Carbon monoxide.
OK.
So, all right.
So sublimation is
happening right now.
We can't see it.
And I'm going to put
those three back in here.
And I ask you to focus
your attention on what you
see between my two hands here.
What do you see
between my two hands?
AUDIENCE: Cylinders.
BASSAM SHAKHASHIRI:
What shape are they?
Cylinders.
How many of them are there?
AUDIENCE: Six.
BASSAM SHAKHASHIRI: And
are they big cylinders
or small cylinders.
AUDIENCE: Big.
BASSAM SHAKHASHIRI:
Well, how big is big?
This big.
Yeah, I know.
That's this big.
[LAUGHTER]
I'm going to ask you to
do the very same thing I
ask my students in my freshman
chemistry course at Wisconsin
to do.
In order to sharpen your
powers of observation
and develop the skills of
reporting these observations,
I ask you to pretend to be the
play-by-play radio announcer,
describing to someone
who is not with us what's
going on, not the TV announcer.
That person has got it made
because the picture tells
almost everything.
So there are how many cylinders?
AUDIENCE: Six.
BASSAM SHAKHASHIRI: And what do
you see inside the cylinders?
AUDIENCE: Colored liquids.
BASSAM SHAKHASHIRI:
Colored liquids.
OK.
I'm listening to
you on the radio.
And what I hear you say is
that there are six cylinders.
And they have in
them colored liquids.
Come on.
Your brain learned a
lot more information
than those two statements.
So they're about
this big, you said.
I can see you on the radio
saying, it's about this big.
You've got to do
better than this.
Are they 100
millimeters in size?
Are they 10 liters in size?
Are they somewhere in between?
Yes.
We put a bracket on it.
When we estimate in science,
we put a bracket on it.
And they have, yes,
colored liquids.
How do you know they're liquids?
They could be gels.
How do we find out?
We shake them up a
little bit because we
know from experience.
It's a keyword.
We learn things.
Our brain learns things.
So we use them.
So they're liquids.
And they seem to be arranged
in some kind of order.
What is the order?
It's the order of the
color in the liquids.
And they're arranged in pairs.
This pair has what
colored liquid in it?
AUDIENCE: Blue.
BASSAM SHAKHASHIRI: This one?
AUDIENCE: Pink.
AUDIENCE: Purple.
BASSAM SHAKHASHIRI: All right.
So I'm going to take
chunks of dry ice
and put them in the cylinders
in a very special way.
And when I get done, you tell
me what the special way is.
AUDIENCE: It's blowing out.
BASSAM SHAKHASHIRI:
What's blowing out?
Do you see any bubbles?
What kind of bubbles are those?
I wish I had a camera
and take a picture
of the facial
expressions I see here.
A lot of interesting
things are happening.
How interesting are they?
Are they interesting
enough that you want
to ask questions about them?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
BASSAM SHAKHASHIRI: Yeah.
Well, you want to
know what's in there?
You already know what's
in there, the dry ice.
I put the dry ice in there.
What did I put the dry ice into?
Into the cylinders that have
colored liquids in them.
And I put the dry ice
in every other cylinder.
I didn't put it
in every cylinder
right, every other
cylinder, leaving one
for comparison purposes.
So these are dyes.
They'll change color when
the pH of the liquid changes.
Because carbon dioxide gas in
water gives us carbonic acid.
Every time we drink a carbonated
beverage, we're drinking acid.
Did you know that?
That's a weak acid.
But these cylinders have
in them a little bit
of sodium hydroxide, before
I did the experiment.
And they changed color because
carbon dioxide, the gas,
combines with the
base that's in there.
And the dyes are
acid/base indicators.
So this pair had an indicator
called bromothymol blue.
This has phenolphthalein.
And this had a
mixture of indicators.
So in this pair, the color
changed from what to what?
AUDIENCE: Blue to yellow.
BASSAM SHAKHASHIRI:
How about this?
AUDIENCE: Pink to--
BASSAM SHAKHASHIRI: To what?
AUDIENCE: Clear.
BASSAM SHAKHASHIRI: Clear.
This is a clear
and colored liquid.
This is a clear--
this is colorless, your right.
Clear and colorless do
not mean the same thing.
From now on, no one
in this audience
is going to confuse the words
"clear" and "colorless."
This is a clear
and colored liquid.
This is a clear and colorless.
So now I ask you to focus your
attention on this cylinder.
Actually, you can
focus your attention
on anything you want to.
You can even not pay
attention if you want to.
We live in a free country.
But if you want to follow
the experiment with me,
I want you to focus your
attention on this one.
And tell me, count them out,
how many different color changes
you see as I drop
the dry ice in there?
[BUBBLING]
I'm listening to
you on the radio.
AUDIENCE: Wow.
BASSAM SHAKHASHIRI: One.
Wow, I heard wow.
What kind of a count is that?
AUDIENCE: Three.
BASSAM SHAKHASHIRI:
Three so far?
Three different color changes.
But you know, I'm listening
to you on the radio.
And you want me to appreciate
what you're seeing.
So what were the color
changes that you saw?
Why couldn't you say those?
You see how we have
to help our brain make
the right observations and
make the right reporting.
So what about this stuff
that's coming off of the top?
What does it look like?
AUDIENCE: Gas.
BASSAM SHAKHASHIRI:
It looks like gas.
But actually what it is--
it looks like smoke.
But it's not smoke.
What's the name of the stuff
that floats up in the sky.
You can just say it.
You don't have to
raise your hand.
Just say it.
AUDIENCE: Clouds.
BASSAM SHAKHASHIRI: Clouds.
It's a fog.
It's fog.
It's a mist.
It's condensed water vapor.
The condensation is taking place
on the cold carbon dioxide gas
bubbles that are coming from
the sublimation process.
That's why sublimation is
happening right now, right
here, and also in this bucket.
But we can't see it.
But over here we can
see it because gas
is mixing with what here?
AUDIENCE: Liquid.
BASSAM SHAKHASHIRI: Liquid.
And here gas is
mixing with what?
AUDIENCE: Gas.
BASSAM SHAKHASHIRI: Gas.
OK.
So I always think, T-H-I-N-K,
T-H-I-N-K, remember that.
If you remember anything
about my visit with you today,
remember to T-H-I-N-K.
Remember to think.
So condensed water
vapor is coming out.
The mist is flowing downward.
Why is the mist
flowing downward?
Because carbon dioxide
gas is denser than air.
It's heavier than air.
And if we knew this,
this is a beautiful way
to be reminded of it.
And if we didn't know
it, we just learned it.
So what I'm going to do here--
because she turned it off.
Ah.
No.
I wanted it on.
Let's see if it still works.
So I'm going to take this
bucket, this bucket right here.
It's empty except for what?
AUDIENCE: Air.
BASSAM SHAKHASHIRI:
You can't see air.
And I'm going to take
the hot boiling--
ah, well, it's hot.
I don't know if it's boiling.
It was boiling.
You could see it.
I'm going to use my gloves now
to protect my hands from heat
because I don't
want to burn myself.
And I'm going to dump
this water in here.
I don't want to get the
water trapped in the gloves
because you know what
then will happen,
what will happen
to my-- here we go.
So what do you see
coming off the top?
AUDIENCE: Steam.
BASSAM SHAKHASHIRI:
Steam is invisible.
You can't see steam.
What are you seeing?
AUDIENCE: Water vapor.
BASSAM SHAKHASHIRI: Water vapor.
This room is full
of water vapor.
Otherwise, my throat would be
drier than it is right now.
What are you seeing
coming off the top?
AUDIENCE: Water vapor.
BASSAM SHAKHASHIRI:
You're seeing a mist.
It's condensed water vapor.
The hot water vapor
hits the cold air.
It condenses.
And then it gets the
same temperature.
It disappears.
So what I'm going to do now
is take the bucket of dry ice
and put the dry
ice right in there.
[YELLS]
[LAUGHTER]
Just be careful not
to touch the water
because the water is very hot.
All right.
OK.
So what I'd like you to do
now is to go back and sit.
Go back and sit where
you were sitting before.
I know that's--
Condensed water
vapor is what we see.
We see the fog is moving?
AUDIENCE: Down.
BASSAM SHAKHASHIRI: Downward.
Why?
Because the condensation
is taking place.
And the carbon dioxide gas,
which is denser than air.
This is a good way
to demonstrate this.
So I'm going to take this out of
the way and put it right here.
This is how they make fog
in the movies sometimes.
Take boiling water,
add dry ice to it.
And you put a fan
on it and blow it.
And I have to tell
you this little story
because it's a true story.
I do a lot of
these presentations
all over the world.
In Madison, Wisconsin,
my adopted hometown,
I was at the airport one time.
And a whole bunch of kids,
about 20, maybe 25 kids,
they saw me from a distance.
They were getting on an
airplane, going on a field trip
to Washington, DC.
And they ran to me.
And they didn't say,
hi, Dr. Shakhashiri.
You know what they said?
Condensed water vapor.
[LAUGHTER]
That's what they said.
They learned it.
They said condensed water vapor.
So they learned it.
OK, good.
All right.
So now, we're going
to do an experiment.
Let's see.
This is moving along
very rapidly here.
I forgot the directions
for the next experiment.
But you know, I brought
my book with me.
So here's my new book.
So is it OK if I open
the book and read
from the book a little bit?
Would that be OK?
Is that OK?
Ah.
You see, this is not
an ordinary book.
This is a hot book.
Actually, it's just
the book covers.
What's on the inside?
I'll show you.
There's a couple of
batteries right here.
I'll walk around so
everybody can see it.
I have two batteries.
Batteries have stored
in them chemical energy.
And there is a filament up here.
And then there is a flint that
I soaked with lighter fluid
when you were not looking.
And what I have not told you
yet, and you have not seen it,
but I'm going to show it to
you and tell you right now,
there's a button down here.
Can you can see the
button down there?
Huh?
What color is the button?
AUDIENCE: Black.
BASSAM SHAKHASHIRI: Come on.
You're doing the
play-by-play description.
Yeah, black.
It is black.
You have to report
your observations.
So you know about
the fire triangle.
It takes three things
to have a fire.
What are they?
Something that burns.
Oxygen, usually from the air.
What's the third one?
Heat, a source of ignition,
a source of ignition.
So you watch how I do this now.
I stand over here.
I move the book
away from my face.
[LAUGHTER]
I'm connecting with you because
you're paying attention.
And I open the book.
And when I push the
button, chemical energy
changes into electrical energy.
And this light bulb filament
is like all other filaments.
It is not 100% efficient.
It gives off light energy and--
and so let's see what happens
when I push the button here,
away from my face.
OK.
You saw that, right?
So you tell me now,
you tell me what
happens when I close the book?
What happened when
I closed the book?
Just say it out loud.
AUDIENCE: Cut off the oxygen.
BASSAM SHAKHASHIRI:
Cut off the oxygen.
You're like the
students in my class.
You give a correct answer,
but not to the question
that I asked.
And that's why people
sometimes don't do well
on tests because they
don't answer the question.
So what was the
question that I asked?
I asked you what happened
when I closed the book?
What happened when
I closed the book?
AUDIENCE: The fire went out.
BASSAM SHAKHASHIRI:
The fire went out.
Why did the fire go out?
[LAUGHTER]
Because there is no
oxygen. You get it.
We have to train our
brains so we are connected
with each other properly.
So I open the book now.
Is there oxygen or not?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
BASSAM SHAKHASHIRI:
But there's no flame.
How come there's no flame?
We're missing the heat.
What should I do?
Stop talking and push
the button, right.
That's what I should do.
So I push the button.
There it is.
I'm running out of fuel.
OK.
So this book cover
is from volume 5.
And now I have used it once.
I cannot take it back
on the airplane with me.
But even if I
could, I don't want
to because I want to give
it to Professor Lippard
as a memento of my visit here.
[APPLAUSE]
So you can use it safely, Steve.
And you know why?
You know why we teach
about the fire triangle?
Not to help people
start fires, but to help
people put out fires.
You think about that.
So let's see.
We've got a couple of
other things going on here.
What am I holding with
my two hands right here?
AUDIENCE: Bottles.
BASSAM SHAKHASHIRI:
What kind of bottles?
Come on.
Do I have to ask all the
questions all the time?
Play-by-play description, right.
Are they what?
What size bottles are they?
What are they made of?
AUDIENCE: Plastic.
BASSAM SHAKHASHIRI:
Do you realize
how much technology
is involved in this,
in just making this bottle?
Look, there's a shoulder here.
There's an opening here.
A lot of science and
applications of science
are involved in making those
two-liter bottles, that
are made of?
AUDIENCE: Plastic.
BASSAM SHAKHASHIRI: Plastic.
They're made of plastic.
And there's a little bit of
a clear and colorless liquid
near the bottom of
each one of them.
And I'm going to tell
you what the liquids are.
The liquid in here
is hydrogen peroxide.
It is 30% hydrogen peroxide, not
what you buy in the drugstore.
What you buying the drugstore
is 3% hydrogen peroxide.
And what do you buy it for?
Because if you have a cut,
you put the hydrogen peroxide
on your wound.
And what do you see?
AUDIENCE: Bubbles.
BASSAM SHAKHASHIRI: Bubbles.
What kind of bubbles are those?
They're oxygen bubbles.
Because hydrogen peroxide
breaks down very,
very, very, very, very, very
slowly into water and oxygen.
But if there is
something that speeds up
that breakup, a catalyst,
then it goes very fast.
And the blood and the skin
have in them such substances.
So I'm going to take what
looks like a small tea bag
right here.
I'm going to put it in there.
And see if we can catalyze the
decomposition or the breakup
of the hydrogen peroxide.
You can see that already--
what do you see on the inside?
What do you see coming
off the top here?
AUDIENCE: Condensed water.
BASSAM SHAKHASHIRI:
Condensed water vapor.
It's a mist.
It's a mist, right?
And where is it coming from?
This reaction of the
breakup of the hydrogen
peroxide into water and
oxygen is exothermic.
It gives off heat.
So the water is boiling.
And the boiling water,
when it hits the cold air,
it condenses.
And we see that
until the temperature
gets to be the same as
the air temperature.
And we don't see it anymore.
So we always like to repeat
the experiment in science.
But before I repeat
the experiment,
I want you to look
very, very closely,
if you haven't been doing
so already, about what else
is happening to the plastic.
But what is this?
What is this?
I'm listening to
you on the radio.
I can't see this.
What is this?
Tell me.
Tell me out loud.
Huh?
The plastic bottle is shrinking.
Amazing.
When I was a student
at Boston University,
I learned that if you take
a substance and you heat it,
it stretches.
But this is plastic.
This is made by people.
So plastics shrink.
You all know that plastics
shrink because you've
heard of shrink wrapping.
How does shrink wrapping works?
You cover something up
with a plastic sheet.
And then what do you do?
You heat it.
How come when we
heat plastic, it
shrinks and when I heat a
piece of copper, it stretches?
How come?
This is not a
rhetorical question.
I want to do T-H-I-N--
what?
"K" about this.
So be thinking about that.
So we repeat the experiment.
We're do the
experiment right here.
And there it is again.
Let's see if the
same thing happens.
As you're watching that, I'm
going to do now an experiment
right here whereby
I have this beaker.
It's volume is about
600 milliliters.
And it's empty, except for?
AUDIENCE: Air.
BASSAM SHAKHASHIRI: All right.
I'm going to put it on
top of this other beaker.
They're going to flip
around like this.
So everybody can see it.
And I'm going to take two
liquids, a clear and colorless
liquid in my right-hand bottle
and a clear and colorless
liquid in the left hand.
OK.
You see that, if you're
paying attention over here.
But if you're still
looking over there,
then you're not watching this.
And that's really
what it's about.
You have the freedom to
choose what you want to do.
And you will be effective
in what you want to do.
Be very careful about it.
So that's kind of
interesting right there.
And you know what?
Don't rush into anything.
I'm rushing right now.
I'm keeping an eye
on the watch here.
You all have other
things you want to do.
You probably want to go
watch the Patriots play.
That's up to you.
But lots of fascinating,
captivating, engaging,
educating, informing,
changes, transformations
are happening over here.
So watch this.
I take this clear and colorless
liquid and I put some of it
in the beaker, about
a hundred milliliters.
How do I know it's about
a hundred millimeters?
I'm reading the markers
here, on the beaker.
And I take about a
hundred millimeters
of a different clear
and colorless liquid.
But you don't know
it's different.
They look the same.
And look at this.
Look what's going to happen now.
AUDIENCE: It's yellow.
BASSAM SHAKHASHIRI:
Isn't that one
of the most fascinating
observations you make?
You take two clear,
colorless liquids.
You mix them together.
And you get a yellow substance,
that is insoluble in water.
And you notice what
happened over here?
So this is-- this fell over.
So it's pretty hot.
I don't want to have it--
there it is.
I want to have it--
it's going to fall over again.
I'll prop it over here.
So the little tea bag
has in it a catalyst
called manganese dioxide, MnO2.
It has large surface area.
It catalyzed the decomposition
of the hydrogen peroxide.
Is this one going to fall off?
We'll wait and see.
This is lead iodide.
I mixed potassium
iodide solution
with lead nitrate solution.
So the magician never tells
you how the trick works.
But in science, we like
to know what's going on.
So I close these
back the same way.
And now I'm going to
ask you a question.
I have a magnet
coated with Teflon.
And it's sitting on top of a
motor, which I want to turn on.
Can you see the bars spin?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
BASSAM SHAKHASHIRI:
And you tell me
what direction is
the bar spinning
when we look down at it?
What direction is it?
AUDIENCE: Clockwise.
BASSAM SHAKHASHIRI: When
you look down at it--
I'll slow it down a little
bit so you can see it better.
AUDIENCE: Clockwise.
BASSAM SHAKHASHIRI:
It's spinning clockwise,
what we call clockwise.
Now, what I would
like you to do is
to visualize that
you're not looking down
at this spinning magnet.
But you're looking up at it.
Imagine there is a
ceiling fan up there.
And it's moving in the
same direction as this bar.
So what is that?
Here's what some of you are
doing, is you're doing this.
And you're looking up.
And what do you see?
What do you see up there?
AUDIENCE: The light.
BASSAM SHAKHASHIRI:
Counter-clockwise.
You're confusing me.
Is this my right
hand or my left hand.
AUDIENCE: Right.
BASSAM SHAKHASHIRI:
I'm looking up at it.
It's my right hand.
I put it down here.
It is my?
AUDIENCE: Right.
BASSAM SHAKHASHIRI: It's
still in my right hand.
You're really confusing me.
What's going on here?
Here's what's going on.
I want everyone in the
audience, everyone,
stick your finger out like this.
And you and I are going
to rotate our fingers
in a clockwise direction.
Go.
Clockwise.
Hey, I said clockwise.
What are you doing?
Clockwise.
Watch me.
AUDIENCE: Clockwise.
BASSAM SHAKHASHIRI:
I'm doing-- look.
When I turn around like this,
I'm doing it clockwise too.
But when I turn around
like this, what do you see?
AUDIENCE: Clockwise.
BASSAM SHAKHASHIRI:
So you have to think.
You have to think
about the perspective
that you have in
making observations.
By the way, where does this
idea of clockwise movement
and counter-clockwise come from?
AUDIENCE: Clocks.
BASSAM SHAKHASHIRI: Clocks.
Yeah, I know.
It comes from clocks.
[LAUGHTER]
Where does it really come from?
Do you know?
AUDIENCE: The Sun.
BASSAM SHAKHASHIRI:
From the sundial.
It's from the sundial.
And as far as we
know, was the sundial
first observed in the
Northern Hemisphere
or in the Southern Hemisphere?
As far as we know, it's in
the Northern Hemisphere.
So I want you to
visualize, like you
did with the ceiling
fan, the sundial
in the Southern Hemisphere.
Oh, yeah.
Right.
I want you to think
about that and see
which direction it's going in.
All right.
It's moving.
So now what I want to
do, two more experiments.
So here's a beaker.
I have a question for you.
Do you suppose there's a way
for me to hold this beaker up
in the air without touching it.
AUDIENCE: Yes.
BASSAM SHAKHASHIRI: So
let me borrow your book.
Now, it's your book, Steve.
I don't mean put it
on a book like this.
I'm touching it right now.
Do you suppose there's a way
to suspend this beaker up
in the air without touching it?
Yes or no.
AUDIENCE: Yes.
BASSAM SHAKHASHIRI: Some
of you are saying yes
because you know how it's done.
And some of you are saying
yes because you trust that I'm
going to show you how to do it.
So here's what
we're going to do.
We're going to take--
you're doing the
play-by-play description.
What is this?
AUDIENCE: A balloon.
BASSAM SHAKHASHIRI: What else
can you tell me about it?
Does it have a color?
AUDIENCE: It's blue.
BASSAM SHAKHASHIRI: Look.
I am told the brain receives
every second about 11
million bits of information.
And a brain can't sort them
all out at the same time.
So we have to
train ourselves how
to make observations
and report them.
So here we go.
Ta-da.
Is the beaker up in air?
AUDIENCE: Yep.
BASSAM SHAKHASHIRI:
Am I holding it?
AUDIENCE: No.
AUDIENCE: Yes.
BASSAM SHAKHASHIRI: So can
you explain what this is?
I pulled it out.
Can you explain how this works?
So I want you to
think about this.
You also know what's going to
happen when I let the air out
of here.
AUDIENCE: Let go.
BASSAM SHAKHASHIRI: Let go.
OK, I'll let go.
You've done that before.
Why does that happen?
Lots of interesting
things happen in science
with familiar items.
So how do you explain
what happened here?
What?
You're thinking about it?
Some people say that when I
inflated the balloon in here,
there was a change
in the pressure.
I want to tell you--
you can think about that too.
I didn't bring it with me.
But I went to the glass shop
at the University of Wisconsin
chemistry department and I sawed
off the bottom of the beaker
and it still works.
So it's not the change
in the pressure.
But everyone here
everyone, everyone,
including the little
kids, know the explanation
as to why this works.
But you haven't
thought about it.
You haven't connected it yet.
So what I'd like you to do
is take both hands right now
and rub them very
fast with each other.
Rub very fast.
What do you feel?
AUDIENCE: Friction.
BASSAM SHAKHASHIRI:
You feel friction?
You feel heat, which is
the result of friction.
As I said, you're like
the students in my class.
So friction.
So can friction be
related to this?
You think about it.
So now what I want to do
is do another experiment
with the balloon right here.
This time, I'll take
what color balloon?
AUDIENCE: Yellow.
BASSAM SHAKHASHIRI: This
balloon has a hole in it
so that doesn't work.
I'll try this one.
I inflate the balloon,
let some air out.
And then I tie it.
And now I'm going to
ask you a question.
Do you suppose there's a way
for me to hold this balloon up
in the air without touching it?
So I don't mean put it
in a beaker like this.
I'm not touching it now.
Do you suppose
there's a way for me
to suspend this up in the air
without touching it, yes or no?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
BASSAM SHAKHASHIRI: Those
of you who say yes--
those of you who
say yes know how
it's done or trust that
I'm going to show you
how it's going to be done.
So suppose I take this
balloon and I blow air in it,
like this.
That was held up in the
air without touching it.
But that's kind of
hard on my neck.
So suppose I take--
suppose I take this.
What is this?
AUDIENCE: Blow dryer.
BASSAM SHAKHASHIRI: Is
the balloon up in the air?
Am I touching it?
AUDIENCE: No.
BASSAM SHAKHASHIRI: What
is holding the balloon up
in the air.
AUDIENCE: Air.
BASSAM SHAKHASHIRI: Air?
There's air right
now, but it's--
now, you're going to
help me with that.
Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Go faster.
BASSAM SHAKHASHIRI: No.
I was pushing the cold one.
Look, you know.
Each one of you knows.
What was coming out
the nozzle here?
What was coming out of nozzle?
A stream of air, right?
A stream-- wind,
that's what it was.
So here we go.
So do it again.
Now, watch what I do here.
Watch how I turn this.
Watch how I turn this
to the side like this.
You can see how big of an
angle you can get away with.
See that.
All right.
All right, I'll have it
back from you please.
You're all thinking about
what the explanation is.
Thank you.
You're all thinking
about the explanation
because what I'm going
to do next is take this.
What is this?
AUDIENCE: It's a ball.
BASSAM SHAKHASHIRI:
A Styrofoam ball.
AUDIENCE: Whoa.
And a balloon.
BASSAM SHAKHASHIRI: And
a balloon, up there.
Am I touching any of them?
AUDIENCE: No.
BASSAM SHAKHASHIRI: What was
holding them up in the air?
Thank you.
Moving air, right.
Look.
You all know this effect.
You stand on a street
corner and a big bus
goes by, what do you feel?
Woo.
And you're driving on a
highway and the big lorry truck
passes by, what do you feel?
AUDIENCE: Nothing.
[LAUGHTER]
BASSAM SHAKHASHIRI:
You know what?
I believe you.
That's your observation.
I respect you for
making an observation.
But watch for it next time, OK?
Now, this is a
scientific principle.
You all know what
this principle is.
It's named after a
Swiss mathematician.
It's called--
AUDIENCE: Magic.
BASSAM SHAKHASHIRI: Bernoulli's
principle, Bernoulli.
Look.
You all know about this.
I don't want to get too
personal about this one.
You took a shower this morning.
You turned the water on.
Did the shower curtain
move in or out,
if you have a shower curtain?
Sometimes we don't
have shower curtains.
So there's a change.
There's a stream of air that
causes things to happen,
as we just saw here.
So now I'm going to
do an experiment.
This experiment,
with this, with this.
What is this?
AUDIENCE: Plastic bag.
BASSAM SHAKHASHIRI: Could
I ask you to help me
with this experiment?
OK.
So what is it that
Lou and I are holding?
A plastic what?
A piece of plastic.
What color is it?
AUDIENCE: Blue.
BASSAM SHAKHASHIRI: Do I
have to ask all the questions
all the time?
AUDIENCE: No.
BASSAM SHAKHASHIRI: No.
You are asking them.
You have to make
these observations.
Look.
How long is it?
It's about what?
Is it about 1 meter, 10 meters?
It's 2 meters in length.
I have an opening
at this end here.
Do you have an opening
over there, Lou?
LOU: No.
BASSAM SHAKHASHIRI: It's sealed.
OK.
So I'm going to
change sides with you.
I'm going to give you
this opening right here.
You hold it like this.
You got it?
And I'd like you to blow
air in here so that we
can count how many
breaths it's going
to take her to inflate this.
And don't make her laugh now.
OK.
Come on, go.
One, two, three, four.
That's enough.
I don't want you
to hyperventilate.
You know what
hyperventilation is?
Is it related to
carbon dioxide gas?
So this is what she
did with four breaths.
Now, I'm going to let the
air out that you put in there
and give you the closed end.
And then I'm going to show
you, if you pay attention,
if you pay attention,
I'm going to show you
how you can inflate this
two-meter long bag with one
breath.
You're smiling at me.
You don't believe me.
Do you remember what she did?
She blew into it the
same way you and I
blow into a paper bag.
So now I'm going
to do it this way.
I'm going to open
this up like this.
I lift it up a little bit
so it's about-- yeah, right.
Here we go.
Let go.
[LAUGHTER]
[APPLAUSE]
Did you see how it was done?
Would you like to try it?
LOU: Yes.
BASSAM SHAKHASHIRI: Yeah.
That's the spirit.
See, Leonardo said, you
know, about experiments.
So I take all the air out.
And now you do it
the way I did it,
not the way you did
it the first time.
One long breath,
right down the middle.
Whenever you're ready.
Close it off.
[LAUGHTER]
Only one.
A lot better than the
first time, right?
[APPLAUSE]
So here's a question for you.
Do you think she has that
much air in her lungs?
AUDIENCE: No.
AUDIENCE: Yes.
BASSAM SHAKHASHIRI: Do you
think I have that much air
in my lungs to blow this?
What's the explanation?
What?
Well, the thing-a-ma-jigger
doesn't have much in air in it
right now.
So look.
You all know the
explanation for this
because we just went through
it in the previous set
of experiments.
What did I blow out of my
mouth and what did she do?
A stream of moving air.
Remember, one of my
slides says connectivity.
You make connections.
You make connections
between what you see
and what you already know.
So a stream of
moving air creates
a partial vacuum and air
comes in from the outside.
That's called "what's
his name" principle.
What's his name?
AUDIENCE: Bernoulli.
BASSAM SHAKHASHIRI: The
whole thing was a setup.
You knew that.
That's why-- OK.
So here's our grand finale.
Here's our grand finale.
It's a repeat of
that experiment,
which we're going to do.
In this, you're doing the
play-by-play description.
What is it?
AUDIENCE: Black.
BASSAM SHAKHASHIRI: Black what?
AUDIENCE: Black tub.
BASSAM SHAKHASHIRI: Black tub.
And what is this?
AUDIENCE: Cylinder.
BASSAM SHAKHASHIRI: And I take
a clear and colorless liquid
from this bottle.
And I put it in there.
And this clear and
colorless liquid
is 30% hydrogen peroxide,
35% hydrogen peroxide.
And I take what?
I put some of this in there.
But I want to help the hydrogen
peroxide break down into water
and oxygen. So what do I need?
I need a catalyst.
I could use manganese dioxide.
But it's not the only catalyst.
I'm going to use this
liquid right here.
This is a clear, but
slightly colored liquid.
It's slightly yellow.
So I'm going to put some of that
in there and see what happens.
AUDIENCE: It's yellow.
BASSAM SHAKHASHIRI:
What's happening?
You're doing the play-by-play
description, not me.
Ah, it's going out
of control here.
I better put it down here.
So this is that the
decomposition of hydrogen
peroxide using potassium iodide
solution as the catalyst.
So the different catalyst caused
a lot of different changes
to happen.
And this is why we
need to learn more
about the science of the
familiar, which is chemistry.
And I want to really
thank you for coming
this afternoon-- this evening.
I want to ask you one more
time, what does my T-shirt say?
AUDIENCE: Science is fun.
BASSAM SHAKHASHIRI: That's what
I like, enthusiasm, science.
So whatever you do,
do it-- do it-- do it
with a purpose in mind.
Try to help the
plasticity in your brain.
But it's not just your brain
that we're talking about.
It's what's in your heart.
Because one of the important
elements of communication
is what you feel in your
heart, which is not something
that was on my slide.
So thank you all very much.
Thank you, Steve.
Thank you, Lou.
Thank you, everybody.
[APPLAUSE]
And remember, no matter
what you do, science is fun.
Thank you very much.
Thanks.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.